- So Brooke, you created a platform
for women over 40 starting a new chapters,
which I think is fantastic.
- It is called Beginning Is Now,
and I really just, especially
during Covid, I thought,
I'm 56 right but I feel
stronger, I feel more powerful,
I feel more confident, I don't feel as-
- I feel like that happens with age.
- [Brooke] And that's-
- Yeah.
- [Brooke] The part to
me that's so amazing.
But when you're over 40 and
you look at what's out there,
we're not marketed too, I don't know-
- But there's not like a lot
of like movies or TV shows,
it's usually like a specific,
like younger or then older.
It's like, there's nothing
generally in that gap-
- Yeah, it's like 20s
or Helen Mirren and she's gorgeous but-
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh my God, I hate her.
Like who looks like that?
- [Kirsten] I think one of
the things is though too,
I feel like I'm at this
age too as an actress
where I'm like, do I just age nicely?
Or like, I think I just gotta get old
so that I can keep with
having good parts too.
Like I kinda have to just like not fall
for the praise of Los Angeles
and just kinda age normally
so you're doing a-
- Well you're doing a beautiful job of it.
- I keep working though.
I feel like to get interesting parts,
you know what I mean?
- It is, it's a hard thing
and I've talked to a lot of...
And you know what?
I never had that conversation with actors,
it's always actresses and it's-
- Oh yeah.
- And it's always 'cause
there's a harder thing
that's always put on women.
- [Kirsten] Like what, yeah,
how it like, what route?
- [Brooke] Yep, Netflix was really-
- [Kelly] And how natural can I age?
- Well you don't want your,
half your conversation
about your part,
like the supporting
conversation to be like,
"Oh what face work did she do?"
You know what I mean?
Like, which would be devastating to me.
- Is that a real-
- [Brooke] Oh yes.
- [Kirsten] Yeah.
- Well what Netflix,
when they originally
talked to me about it,
it was a woman who in this
one particular division said,
"We are interested in
women over a certain age."
Over 40, they're saying.
Because there're empowered women in there.
And she said, "That's what
we're gearing towards."
So it's really, it's lovely
that to hear a network
say that that's their focus, you know,
and it's a section of Netflix, you know,
but it is, they, and that's
what she wants to do,
this executive, and I was
so happy that, you know,
they weren't trying to make me eat 30.
Do you know what I mean?
Like it's, I was my age
and I was acting my age
and in myself, and really
just there's pride in it,
and I love that there's
starting to be representation
like that in at least in these movies.
- And as a woman that's about
to be 40, I love watching it.
Like, I don't really
relate, sorry, anymore
to a lot of the younger, like,
you know what I'm saying?
There's, there's like,
there should be like
sections for all of it.
Like, we like to watch different things,
and maybe people, I don't
know our own age doing stuff.
So yeah.
- And there's romance,
you know, and there's humor
and there's, you know, it's,
there's, it's parts of it that
are sort of just sexy enough,
you know what I mean?
But, but it's, and it's presenting women
with all of their facets, you know?
And I think that that's...
It took me decades to grow into myself
and not compare myself or say,
"Oh God, they want me to do this,
or I'm not this enough
or I'm not that another."
- Well the reason why you
probably did that though
is 'cause people put that
on us when we're young.
- [Kirsten] They do, especially,
yeah, are you kidding me?
Of course, yeah, all of us
like had different versions of that.
You probably had it the
worst, Brooke, right?
I mean-
- I mean, I wasn't, I mean,
there was no social media when I was-
- That's true.
- You know?
I mean, it was...
I had my own set of different things
that I had to grapple
with, insecurity wise,
but it was, you know,
I was called a face of
a decade, it's like-
- And that's a lot of pressure.
- Who decides that, you know?
- It's a lot of pressure-
- Feel free to call mine
the face of the decade.
I don't know who decides, but
no, that's a lot of pressure-
- The arbitrary ridiculousness of it.
So what I did was became the
class clown, self-deprecate.
- Oh me too.
- Oh look at me, look at me,
waka, waka, waka.
And I need to diffuse
the air, I need to have,
not be threatening to women, I need to-
- Oh my God, that's how I
feel sometimes too, yeah.
- And then you start to believe it,
then you start living in
your comments about yourself
and your self-deprecation and you know,
and that's not healthy either.
And so it's about finding
that balance of saying,
you know, I mean, by
virtue of getting older,
I would be considered a disappointment
because I would've had to have
died when I was, you know,
18 or something like
that to, it's not funny,
but like to preserve
what everybody has on their
psyche about me, right?
- Because at the end of the day,
sometimes people view you as a product
and not the actual person,
so they just see one thing,
yeah, totally.
- And so I had to,
throughout my life really
just reveal myself emotionally
and in all ways so that that's
what I could own, you know?
So it wasn't just-
- I feel the same,
like same in a different way too, yeah.
Yeah, I was lucky working
with Sofia Coppola
at such a young age, because at 16,
when you don't feel good about yourself,
she made me feel beautiful.
So I had that to kind of
take me through the like
more masculine, like,
energy films and things.
I didn't look to anybody
or dress in a certain way
on the carpet that like I had to be sexy.
I dressed the way I
wanted to dress, you know?
- That's a beautiful thing
to have that influence
so from a woman at a young age.
- I got lucky that I had that
at such a young age, yeah.
- [Brooke] And I never had that,
and I got male directors
who loved the men-
- We might edit this out.
I had a photographer literally
look at me, and I was,
it was literally right
after American Idol,
and it was like 20 years
ago, and it was, he was like,
"Man, you would be so pretty
if you lost 20 pounds."
And I was like, "Oh my God,
how much weight do you
think you need to lose
to be attractive?"
- Awesome that you said that by the way!
I love that you said that back to him.
(audience applauding)